guten tag wo wäre der mensch freier als
in der kunst dort wird er zum schöpfer
seiner selbst zum schöpfer neuer welten
und handlungsweisen das paradebeispiel
solch eines freiheitsliebenden menschen
sitzt mir jetzt gegenüber es ist mario
vargas llosa einer der bedeutendsten
schriftsteller unserer zeit und neben
vielen anderen preisen auch preisträger
des literatur nobelpreises 2010 aber
gasthäuser vielen dank dass wir heute
hier bei ihnen in ihrem haus in madrid
zu gast sein dürfen nichts zu danken
es ist mir eine freude er war das was
sie sind nicht nur einer der prägenden
schriftsteller unserer gegenwart sie
sind auch einer ihrer bedeutendsten
denker vor allem auch ein politisch
engagierter intellektueller das denken
beginnt ja meist mit einer frage welche
frage beschäftigt sie derzeit am
intensivsten
ich denke über vieles nach da gibt es
nicht nur eine frage aus politischer
beschäftigt etwa der verfall der
demokratie aus kultureller sicht ist es
der verfall der kultur in unserer zeit
ich denke dass die kultur mehr menschen
erreicht als in der vergangenheit
doch es handelt sich um eine
minderwertige kultur
man könnte es im triumph der bilder über
die ideen sehen sie eine verbindung
zwischen diesen beiden verfalls phänomen
sehen sie in unserer zeit wird den
bildern machen es in kino und fernsehen
in den sozialen netzwerken ein vorrang
gegenüber den ideen eingehen
dadurch erreicht die kultur viel mehr
menschen als früher
ich glaube dass die eliten verschwinden
aber die kultur die menschen erreicht
ist arm und minderwertig geworden die
bilder sind nicht mit gedanken
angereichert die bilder haben die dänen
auf gewisse weise ersetzt
wenn wir vom verfall sprechen und von
der politik dann wäre ja auch vom
verfall der lateinamerikanischen
politischen landschaft zu sprechen in
ihrem heimatland peru sind die letzten
drei präsidenten derzeit im gefängnis in
venezuela herrscht ein diktator stelle
hungersnot einer art bürgerkrieg in
brasilien ein rechtspopulist der auch
kein interesse an einer offenen
gesellschaft hat das sah vor 30 jahren
doch sehr viel optimistischer
vielleicht sogar utopische aus wie vor
30 jahren hatten wir die statuen
praktisch in ganz lateinamerika mit
ausnahme von costa rica
heute hingegen haben wir in den meisten
lateinamerikanischen ländern demokratie
diese sind jedoch stark von korruption
betroffen
das große problem unserer zeit in der
kein amerika ist meiner meinung nach die
korruption die touren gibt dass die
lateinamerika wenige venezuela kuba die
anderen länder sind unvollkommene
demokratie aber einen unfall kommune
demokratie ist eine diktatur fortsetzen
das große problem dem wir uns heute
stellen müssen ist die korruption
sie ist allgegenwärtig im fall von peru
betrifft sie fünf präsidenten die
entweder in haft sitzen gegen die
rechtlich ermittelt wird oder die
geflüchtet sind
das ist eine art symbol dafür was in
vielen lateinamerikanischen demokratien
geschieht
es gibt glücklicherweise ein paar außen
haben chile uruguay
aber ich glaube das große problem in
lateinamerika ist die korruption im
gegensatz zu europa dort ist der
populismus das große problem die
nationalismen die wiederaufnahmen und
die demokratie zwar nicht verdrängen sie
aber immer stärker ausbauen
wenn wir an die strahlkraft der idee
einer offenen gesellschaft an einer
demokratie denken und wir sehen die
dysfunktionalen demokratien
beispielsweise wenn großbritannien
teilweise den usa auch in lateinamerika
dann kann man denken vielleicht ist die
demokratie gar nicht die beste form wir
sehen sehr effektive teilweise auch sehr
vernünftige regime in china in singapur
techno kathrin ist die zeit der großen
demokratischen ideale vielleicht vorbei
ich glaube dass die demokratischen
ideale sehr lebendig sind die menschen
streben auf ganz natürliche weise nach
in einem rechtsstaat zu leben in dem die
menschenrechte geachtet werden indem die
justiz unabhängig agiert und verbrechen
bestraft
das sind zutiefst menschliche ideale und
ich glaube dass sie auch für menschen in
der dritten welt erreichbar sind die
menschen in sehr armen ländern mit etwas
primitiven kulturen problem aber das
große problem ist dass sich die
institutionen oft aufgrund von internen
korruption verschlechtern
der verfall der institutionen ist
gravierend das liegt unter anderem daran
dass wir keine unabhängigen richter
haben richter die verbrechen bestrafen
und oftmals wählt das volk macht habe
die entweder schon korrupt sind oder es
im amt werden weil sie nicht mit strafen
rechnen müssen
aber eine entwicklung die doch sehr
viele europäer besonders besorgt hat ist
dass ein land wie england mit einer
langen demokratischen tiefen tradition
sich in eine lage gebracht hat in der
selbst fast unregierbar für sich selbst
wurde
england ist sehr traurig ich lebte viele
jahre in england und bewunderte die
englischen institutionen und
demokratische einstellung der bürger
und doch sind sie einem absolut
primitiven von demagogie geprägten
nationalismus verfallen
und dafür steht der praxis exit ist eine
art schritt zurück in richtung der
schlimmsten unterentwicklung und das in
einem land das uns als vorbild für die
welt erschien
was bedeutet das dass sie demokratie
immer bedroht ist es gibt immer diesen
ruf der horde er selbst in den
fortschrittlichsten ländern die
institutionen und die qualität der
demokratie angreifen kann
daher halte ich die permanente
mobilisierung einer gesellschaft für
sehr wichtig es geht darum diesen
verfall zu bremsen die ein land wie etwa
venezuela an den rand der zerstörung
bringen kann wenn es wieder war eine
demokratie venezuela ist eines der
potenziellen reichsten länder der welt
und es fiel in die hände einer bande von
demagogen die den sozialismus wieder
aufleben lassen wollten indem sie den
kubanischen modell folgt und was haben
sie erreicht
sie haben dieses land praktisch zerstört
mehr als drei millionen menschen sind
geflüchtet
das land ist am verhungern es gibt keine
arbeit keine medikamente kein essen
letztlich wird es von einer
korrumpierten die der bande regiert die
sehr hart und repressiv vorgeht
repressive das ist ein äußerst
tragisches beispiel einerseits ist es
sehr traurig für die venezolaner
andererseits ist es ein beispiel dafür
was man nicht tun sollte welches modell
man nicht freunden sollte denn
offensichtlich für dieses modell ein
land nicht aus der armen und es
beseitigt keine ungerechtigkeiten
sondern schafft schlimmere
ungerechtigkeiten als die die es
beseitigen will
sie erscheint dass ihr gesamtes werk von
dieser spannung zwischen einem
individuum und den zumutungen der
gemeinschaft getragen ist bereits erstes
buch die stadt und die hunde ist ein
starkes individuum der in einer
gemeinschaft ist in der nicht
hineingehört ist das für sie ein ganz
zentrales thema ihres schreibens in
ihrer existenz diese spannung zwischen
individuum und gemeinschaft nun eine der
größten fortschritte der menschheit war
die erfindung des individuums das
individuum gab es nicht am anfang zur
zeit der stämme
die menschen fühlten sich in der
gemeinschaft geschützt
das kollektiv war ihr schutz vor einer
welt die sie als feindselig empfangen
durch den fortschritt der zivilisation
bildete sich mit der zeit das individuum
heraus die fähigkeit sich vor den
anderen zu unterscheiden ist eine der
größten errungenschaften der
zivilisation anders zu sein
eigene ideen haben zu können auch wenn
sie im widerspruch zu denen der anderen
stehen zum beispiel die sexualität oder
sogar das geschlecht frei wählen zu
können
das sind rechte die wir dank der
zivilisation haben den individualismus
aufzugeben ist also eine verrücktheit
ein rückschritt in die zeit der stimmen
das bedeutet für mich nationalismus das
wiederaufflammen des nationalismus ist
zb sehr schädlich für den aufbau von
europa in der dritten welt hat es immer
nationalisten gegeben und diese wurden
stets von demagogen befeuert das ist
ihre stimme der ruf nach einer perfekten
gesellschaft wie es tatsächlich nie
gegeben hat
es hat nie eine so homogene integre
gesellschaft gegeben
in der alle die gleiche sprache sprechen
die gleichen bräuche pflegen die
gleichen götter anbeten
das ist eine ideologische fantasie
welche die länder zurück wirft die sich
nie verlieren und diese fantasie
bekämpft man im wesentlichen mit ideen
aber heutzutage erleben wir den verfall
der idee sie werden von bildern ersetzt
von bildern die viel elementarer
fiktiver und künstliche erscheinen das
hat schon wieder aufflammen der
nationalismus geführt was wir meiner
meinung nach sehr energischen
entschieden bekämpfen müssen wenn wir
wollen dass die zivilisation weiter
voranschreitet und dass man korrigiert
was schlecht läuft
wir wünschen uns ja keine rückkehr zu
den schlimmsten aspekten der
vergangenheit
jetzt hat die europäische kultur ein
genre ein literarisches genre
hervorgebracht dass die individualität
feiert wie kein anderes milan kundera
sagt der roman ist das paradies der
individualität ist ein alter traum der
menschheit in praktisch jedem land gibt
es diesen traum einer perfekten
gesellschaft in viele auf das nächste
leben projizieren auf das leben nach dem
tod
und manche glauben an ihre weise dass
sich das paradies hier auf erden
erschaffen lässt
aber das paradies lässt sich nicht
erschaffen das paradies sieht für alle
anders aus jeder hat eine eigene
vorstellung vom perfekten leben
was wir jedoch erreichen können ist ein
besseres leben als das was wir hart und
das ist die große errungenschaft der
westlichen kultur
sie hat die barbarei und das primitive
animalische leben unserer vorfahren
zurückgedrängt und eine welt geschaffen
die natürlich nicht perfekt ist und es
auch nie sein wird
die aber weitaus besser ist als die
frühere wird das sagte auch der
philosoph karl popper bei seinem letzten
besuch in spanien wenige monate vor
seinem tod
jemand sagte zu ihm herr kopper die welt
ist in einem sehr schlechten zustand
ja meint ja das stimmt es herrschen
gewalt kriege armut krankheiten
aber wenn diese gedanken sie überfallen
sollten sie den mut nicht verlieren
denken sie daran das ist uns bei allem
was in unserer zeit falsch läuft noch
nie besser gegangen ist
nie ist es uns besser gegangen das ist
eine große wahrheit
noch nie hat die gesellschaft zu große
anstrengungen unternommen um die
unterschiede zu verringern um den
schwachen zu helfen den menschen die
nicht für sich selbst aufkommen können
nie haben wir so viel erreicht wie in
unserer zeit
die fortschritte sind außergewöhnlich
viele dinge laufen schlecht und können
korrigiert werden
aber man korrigiert sie nicht indem man
das paradies sucht sondern auf
intelligente und pragmatische weise und
im rahmen der freiheit und vielfalt
welche die demokratie bietet die
demokratie ist die große errungenschaft
der große beitrag der westlichen
zivilisation für die gesamte
das ist also ganz klar der weg den es
zugehen aber man muss sich im klaren
darüber sein dass man perfektion nie
erreichen kann
es ist eine immerwährende suche wenn sie
sprachen davon dass es kein paradies auf
erden gibt dann gibt es ja doch welten
die man künstlich schaffen kann
der roman autor schafft eine künstliche
welt so wie sie sein könnte oder sein
sollte
worin sehen sie die aufgabe eines
schriftstellers heute in der mehrung und
vertiefung der menschlichen in die
validität ich glaube der große beitrag
ist die aufgabe des romans der literatur
ganz allgemein ist es einen kritischen
geist zu bewahren
eine haltung des widerstands gegen alles
etablierte die idee dass das was wir
haben nicht genug ist dass man etwas
besseres anstreben kann und es möglich
ist dies zu erreichen
das ist die grosse rolle der literatur
die literatur macht aus den lesern
unbefriedigte menschen wieder gegenwart
kritisch gegenüber steht ein großes
literarisches werk zeigt wie arm das
reale leben ist im vergleich zu jenem
dass wir uns vorstellen können dass wir
mit der fantasie und der feder
erschaffen können ich würde sagen die
funktion der kultur ist letztendlich
diesen zustand der beklemmung aufrecht
zu erhalten diese lust auf ein besseres
leben was uns menschen ja auch aus
das ist für mich fundamental und dafür
brauchen wir freiheit ohne freiheit kann
die literatur praktisch nicht existieren
sie wird zu propaganda von einer von den
machthabern kontrollierten literatur die
literatur und die freiheit sind also
unter tel
und die literatur ist ein wesentliches
element im leben eines kritisch
denkenden bürger eine ideale demokratie
ist von bürgern bewohnt die sich nicht
manipulieren lassen sie sich von den
machthabern dieser welt nicht umgarnen
oder täuschen lassen
es sind bürger man die realität kritisch
gegenüberstehen und die vor allem ihre
ideen nicht aufgeben und etwa aufgrund
von emotionen und leidenschaft emotionen
und leidenschaft sind aus politischer
perspektive sehr gefährlich aus
individueller perspektive ist es
wunderbar leidenschaften zu haben
aber in der politik ist es am
wichtigsten rational zu handeln
sie haben jetzt als schriftsteller eine
art intellektuelle autobiografie
vorgelegt der ruf der horde das setzt
sich mit ihren lese erlebnissen einer
spezifischen politischen tradition
auseinander den liberalismus diese
tradition war ihnen ja kulturell und
auch von der generation her gar nicht in
die wiege gelegt weil fast alle
lateinamerikanischen schriftsteller
ihrer generation er dem sozialismus oder
dem kommunismus an ihnen
wie kam es zu dieser verbindung und das
ist ihm daran so wichtig tatsächlich war
ich als junger mann kommunist ich sagen
würde die unruhige jugend in meiner
generation
wir glaubten der sozialismus sei die
lösungen für lateinamerika er würde uns
von den diktatoren befreien
von diesen egoistischen minderheiten
denen praktisch alle produktionsmitteln
in unserer gesellschaft gehörten
revolution
dann kam die kubanische revolution die
diesen ideen großen auf stoffe li und da
merkten wie ich und ein paar andere dass
der sozialismus nicht zu perfekt war wie
wir gedacht hat
er löst zwar einige soziale probleme
doch gleichzeitig schule riesige andere
probleme den mangel an freiheit eine
wirtschaftspolitik die nirgendwo
erfolgreich war
diese freiheit war sehr wichtig es war
essenziell nicht einer allmächtigen
willkür unterworfen zu sein
einer macht die praktisch ungebremst
walten konnte ohne eine kritische
opposition die ihre grenzen setzt
für mich war dieser übergang vom
kommunismus zur demokratie nicht leicht
darf ich kurz frank gab es da ein
bekehrung erlebnis ein eine erfahrung wo
sie gesagt haben ich kann das nicht mehr
ich kann mich mit dieser idee nicht mehr
identifizieren
in den 1960 er jahren war ich fünf mal
in kuba und mitte der 60er jahre empfand
ich zum ersten mal ernüchterung im
zusammenhang mit der kubanischen
revolution
das war als sie um up gegründet wurden
knapp ist die abkürzung für einen
euphemismus
die buchstaben stehen für
militäreinheiten zur unterstützung der
produktion in wirklichkeit waren das
konzentrationslager dorthin brachte man
konnte revolutionäre gewöhnliche
straftäter und homosexuellen ich hatte
guten kontakt zu einer gruppe von
künstlern dichtern tänzern kunst malern
die sich entfernte die brücke nannte
unter ihnen gab es viele homosexuelle
die sich alle sehr mit der revolution
identifizierten sie davon überzeugt dass
die revolution nicht nur das
gesellschaftliche leben verändern würde
sondern auch die moralischen
vorstellungen und dass die freiheit
bringen würde
auch die sexuelle freiheit ich erlebte
mein erstes trauma als ich erfuhr dass
viele dieser jungen leute von el puente
in konzentrationslagern gefangen
gehalten worden
einige hatten selbstmord begangen ich
weiß noch dass ich viele castro den ich
zuvor nie getroffen hatte einen brief
schrieb geschrieben von meiner sorge
unterstützung in anbetracht dieser
maßnahmen daraufhin erhielt ich eine
einladung zu einem gespräch mit ihm
wir waren eine gruppe von
schriftstellern wie wohl alle auf ihre
weise gegen roma protestiert haben
wir waren zwölf stunden von acht uhr
abends bis 8 uhr morgens
es war beeindruckend mit ihm zu
diskutieren
denn er war eine naturgewalt aber die
gründe die ernannte überzeugten nicht
nicht und von da an wurde meine haltung
zur kubanischen revolution und zum
sozialismus im allgemeinen zunehmend
kritischer aller revolution kubaner
partikularismus carly simon kjaer an
dann kam es zu sogenannten padilha krise
um den dichter eduard popp adili an
denen sie sich vielleicht erinnern
dieser dichter identifizierten sich sehr
mit der revolution
er wurde sogar außenhandelsminister er
kritisierte die kulturpolitik in einigen
punkten
darauf wurde er eingesperrt und als
cia-agent bezeichnet das war absurd und
denkt dagegen protestierten viele von
uns und da brach sich mit der
kubanischen revolution
viele europäische intellektuelle die
zwar nicht kommunistisch aber sie links
waren wie sarrazin oder via
oder enzensberger in deutschland
unterzeichneten diesen protest und ich
glaube viele von ihnen brachen wie ich
mit der kubanischen revolution
das war für mich der ausgangspunkt für
eine neubewertung der demokratie ich
hatte viele jahre in paris gelebt und
zog dann nach england
ich lebte während der gesamten amtszeit
von margaret thatcher dort das war für
mich sehr wichtig wie ich in diesem buch
auch beschreiben darf ich dann noch mal
kurz nachfragen weil das war ende der
60er jahre der noch etwas anderes sehr
wichtiges passiert ist der boom wie er
heißt die explosion der line up
lateinamerikanischen kultur und
literatur in europa gabriel garcía
márquez carlos fuentes kortas und
natürlich auch ihr werk sie waren die
protagonisten die wichtigsten personen
dieser neuen kultur hat sie das nicht
auch in dieser gruppe isoliert haben sie
da ihren sozialen kontext ein bisschen
verloren wobei das heißt bei die für
mich war es wunderschön das mitzuerleben
europa eher westen und vielleicht die
ganze welt entdeckten das ist in
lateinamerika nicht nur diktatoren und
revolution gab sondern dass aus
lateinamerika auch eine interessante
kreative und originelle literatur kann
die lateinamerikaner entdeckten
lateinamerika in europa das war auch bei
mir der fall
als ich in peru lebte wusste ich kaum
was sich sonst noch auf meinem kontinent
tat es herrschte ein großer
kommunikations mangel in lateinamerika
und oft wussten terraner nicht was
kulturell in ecuador chile kolumbien
oder brasilien
wir entdeckten dass es ein kontinent gab
dessen menschen eine gemeinschaft
bildeten mit den gleichen problemen den
gleichen geschichten und
der gleiche sprache gestoppt hier
entstand eine interessante literatur
eine natürliche recht kritische
literatur und gleichzeitig auch eine
freie kreative und erfinderische
literatur das war wirklich eine sehr
anregende erfahrung denn das ermöglichte
vielen von uns auch das gruppengefühl
zunächst die freundschaft die da sehr
anregend durch das teilen der
anerkennung konnten uns viel intensiver
als vorher der literatur widmen
diese freundschaftliche geist und die
brüderlichkeit waren nicht von langer
dauer
die politik spaltet er uns wie immer
aber es waren ein paar sehr anregende
jahre anregend war vor allem die
entdeckung lateinamerikas durch seine
schriftsteller und auch durch die leser
denn die menschen begannen die
lateinamerikanischen schriftsteller zu
lesen
dadurch entstand meiner meinung nach
eine viel engere kulturelle verbindung
in lateinamerika als es sie in der
vergangenheit gegeben hat diese
magischen jahre des booms endeten der
freundschaft zerbrach die politischen
ausrichtungen wurden andere sie haben
gesagt ein zentrales erlebnis war die
erfahrung der konzentrationslager und
kuba und sie erzählen in diesem buch
auch dass es ein lektüre lebt lebt es
gab nämlich des werkes von karl raimund
popper die offene gesellschaft und ihre
feinde die ihm intellektuell einen neuen
weg öffnete was war für sie das zentrale
an diesem buch es war das gesamtes
essentiell
ich hatte schon in frankreich begonnen
die gerade denker zu lesen
die ersten waren vielleicht renoir und
schon froh als ich nach england kam
trieben mich also bereits ein paar
liberale ideen
aber prägend für mich war vor allem die
erfahrungen mit der regierung von cross
edge die in england eine wahrhaftige
revolution auslöst die heute sehr
kritisch betrachtet wird immer noch
diese zeit für die engländer war der
gedanke der freiheit ein
aber mit dem land ging es abwärts
und das hatte vor allem zu tun mit der
in massiven präsenz des staates im
alltag in der wirtschaft in der
gesellschaft die freiheiten wurden zwar
strikt respektiert auch das land zerfiel
ist verarmt
es war als würde das leben ins mittelmaß
abrutschen sehr beeindruckend
revolutionierte das alles sie gab der
demokratie neue vitalität
sie entwickelte sich zu einer wahren
gliederung die sagte wir müssen uns
gegenüber dem kommunismus nicht schämen
wieso auch was hat der kommunismus
vollbracht dass wir uns ihm unterlegen
fühlen sein
sie entfachte eine wahrhaftige
revolution wie englands wirtschaft der
gesellschaft und wie ich glaube auch der
politik enorm spur
vor diesem hintergrund begann ich denke
wie kein papa zu lesen und zu studieren
eine große entdeckung war tatsächlich
kein top profi cha bezeichnete ihn als
von großen philosophen der freiheit jene
zeit und ich glaube damit hatte sie sehr
recht sie sagte sie habe sich von hayek
beraten lassen den ich nicht gekannt
hatte auch ihn begann ich zu lesen die
autoren die in diesem buch vorkommen
sind jene die mich im rahmen meiner
als demokratischen überzeugungen zum
liberalismus führen zu einem
liberalismus der pragmatisch und nicht
fanatisch damit meine ich nicht einen
liberalismus der in der freien
marktwirtschaft die lösung für alle
sieht es ist ein liberalismus bei dem
die ideen wichtig sind er vor allem
flexibel ist und davon ausgeht dass sich
reform an die umstände des jeweiligen
landes und der gesellschaft anpassen
muss vor allem ist es ein liberalismus
der sensibel ist für gesellschaftliche
fragen wie einem smith der vater des
liberalismus der immer sehr
sensibilisiert war für das thema der
armut ganz im gegenteil zu allem was
über den liberalismus gesagt wurde
nämlich dass er callt und unmenschlich
sei und nur in mathematischen formeln
denke in diesem buch versuche ich
darzulegen dass das nicht stimmt und
dass der liberalismus sind die
demokratie unzertrennbar werden dass es
unvorstellbar ist dass der liberalismus
diktaturen militärdiktaturen zulassen
könnte denn bezüglich klärung der
äußerst brutale diktatur von kino chat
wurde behauptet dass es sich dort um
eine diktatur der neoliberalen handelt
alles es gab gut gemeinte
wirtschaftsreformen chile
aber es war ein absolut despotisches
brutales und intolerantes regime das hat
mit liberalismus nichts zu tun
darf ich noch mal nachfragen popper
nimmt ja in diesem buch einen sehr
zentralen raum ein auch in ihrer lese
biografie sagen sie dass karl raimund
popper für mich die erweckung war das
ist ja eigentlich erst mal ein
wissenschaftsphilosophie kommt ein
schriftsteller dazu sich sein weltbild
von einem wissenschafts philosophen
revolutionieren zu
von nina vision der provision körper ist
zutiefst kritisch gegenüber dem
kommunismus um den radikalen sozialismus
wie er in der sowjetunion in der
volksrepublik china und in den so
genannten volks demokratien aufgebaut
werden sollte in wirklichkeit erfüllte
sich alles was papa vorhergesagt hatte
das spektakuläre scheitern des
sozialismus der die großen
gesellschaftlichen bedürfnisse
befriedigen konnte das wirtschaftliche
scheitern war dramatisch nicht nur in
der sowjetunion sondern auch in der
volksrepublik china während der
kulturrevolution das verschwinden der
sowjetunion und die transformation der
volksrepublik china in eine wirtschafts
diktatur eine diktatur aber mit einer
kapitalistischen wirtschaft das sind die
besten beispiele dafür dass der
sozialismus nicht funktioniert dass er
die probleme nicht löst und die zeigen
dass das modell der westlichen
demokratie gesellschaften hervorgebracht
hat die am wenigsten fehlerhaft ziehen
gesellschaften in denen es immer die
möglichkeit gibt fehler zu korrigieren
dinge zu verbessern ist dass die idee
von popper dass man falsifiziert bleibt
dass man versuche unternimmt zu
verbessern und sie für die empirie offen
hält karl popper verteidigt die
demokratie und zwar die offene
demokratie denn es gibt auch
populistische demokratien demokratien
des sogenannten dritten weg
der dritte weg ist eine der großen
karikaturen unserer zeit
heute hört man nicht mehr viel davon
doch es gab eine zeit in der man darüber
sprach in der realität gibt es natürlich
nicht nur einen weg aber in einer
offenen demokratie
gibt es gewaltenteilung die bürger
werden respektiert die machthaber können
durch wahlen ausgetauscht werden diese
gesellschaften haben die freiheit
ausgeweitet nicht nur auf politischer
und gesellschaftlicher sondern auch auf
der wirtschaftlichen ebene
es sind die gesellschaften die auf
geflügel sid sie haben den höchsten
lebensstandard erreicht
der kapitalismus unserer zeit ist nicht
der kapitalismus die neunzehnte
jahrhundert die minen englands mit
kindern führte visa berlin einmal sagte
dieser kapitalismus hat sich grundlegend
verändert und zwar gerade wegen
gesellschaftliche anliegen heute nächste
reformen zu die die bedingungen für die
menschen verbessern oder diktaturen zu
errichten ohne solche starren
monolithischen regierungen zu etablieren
die länder zerstört haben wie zum
beispiel der sozialismus in venezuela
kann man so auch ihr etwas rätselhaftes
zitat verstehen ein wahrer liberaler ist
er links die dienende rechten und der
linken sind in unserer zeit kaum
realistisch sie standen mal für eine
klare ideologische trennen
aber heute nehmen wir den fall spanien
die unabhängigkeitsbewegung kataloniens
soll von links kommen sie wären links
aber gibt es etwas reaktionäres etwas
rassistisches als sich den übrigen
spanien überlegen zu fühlen weil man in
katalonien geboren wurden
das ist eine dummheit die jeder wie soll
ich sagen ideologischen kraft entbehrt
ganz im gegenteil es ist eine groteske
karikatur dessen was demokratie
nicht nur die meinen es gäbe unterlegen
und überlegene völker das glauben
nationalisten und das glauben auch die
katalanischen nationalisten wie kann das
links sein
die linke galt immer als sehr sensibel
für gesellschaftliche problem aber diese
sensibilität haben jede gesellschaft
entwickelt die auf diesem gebiet
fortgeschritten sind nicht wahr
welche länder europas haben den höchsten
lebensstandard wo ist das leben besser
in schweden
in der schweiz sind das sozialistische
länder
es sind demokratischen länder die eine
grundlegend liberale politik verfolgen
und das hat ihnen ökonomischen
fortschritt ermöglicht dank dessen sie
in europa eine vorreiterrolle einnehmen
diese beispiele sind sie im stand fest
sicher gibt es informationen des
liberalismus es gibt halt die mit dem
demokratischen und gesellschaftlichen
liberalismus nicht vereinbar sind
und dann muss man zweifellos zu weisen
vorurteile sind inakzeptabel
inakzeptabel ist alles was dazu führt
die menschen nach ihrem glauben ihrer
religion oder ihrer rasse einzuteilen
oder zu unterscheiden
aber das sagen auch alle großen
liberalen denker die in einen auftauchen
und daher versuche ich ein liberaler zu
sein wenn man ihr buch liest und die
eindrückliche kraft und auch eleganz der
liberalen gedanken nachvollzieht dann
gibt es ein stilles paradox im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert gerade die
menschen die von der freiheit des wortes
leben die schriftsteller haben sich in
ganz geringer zahl nur zu dieser
tradition bekannt wie kann man das
eigentlich erklären
ich glaube die erklärung ist hier ein
schriftsteller suchen das paradies
schriftsteller suchen die perfektion
gibt es auf gesellschaftlichem gebiet
nicht
die perfektion lässt sich in der kultur
finden in der malerei der poesie in der
musik natürlich vielleicht in den
gedanken der philosophie aber in der
menschlichen realität gibt es diese
perfektion nicht und es wird sie nie
geben die demokratie ist die politische
anerkennung dieser unvollkommenheit die
das menschliche sein charakterisiert
deshalb betrachten die meisten
schriftsteller die demokratie mit großer
geringschätzung
sie glauben an diese fantasien von
perfekten gesellschaften in denen es
keine unbefriedigte bedürfnisse mehr
gibt und in denen uns alles zur
verfügung steht
aber das gibt es nicht das ist fiktion
und der beweis dafür ist der niedergang
der großen sozialistischen imperien
unserer zeit
es gibt kein einziges beispiel einer
radikal sozialistischen oder
kommunistischen gesellschaft erfolg
gehabt hätte keine einzige alle sind auf
spektakuläre weise gescheitert
zurückgelassen haben die länder in denen
die menschen solche angst vor der idee
des sozialismus haben dass sie oftmals
reaktionär werden sogar reaktion er
antidemokratisch sowie in ungarn ungarn
ist ein haarsträubender fall in europa
ein land das nach der leidvollen
erfahrung des kommunismus nun immer
undemokratischer wird sie sagen also es
gibt einen psychologischen effekt der
künstler will perfektion die demokratie
ist per se in perfekt und deswegen will
der künstler utopische entwürfe die
meistens antidemokratisch sind genau sie
haben das sehr gut zusammengefasst
die suche nach dem paradies führt oft in
die hölle das widerfährt vielen
schriftstellern die die ganzen
kommunistischen sozialistischen
fantasien verschlungen haben
entstanden sind sollen wie in venezuela
venezuela ist heute eine regelrechte
erhöhen
es könnte das reichste land
lateinamerikas seien den höchsten
lebensstandard haben
doch es ist eine regelrechte hölle die
millionen von venezolanern sagt haben
mindestens drei millionen sind aus dem
land geflohen
wie kann das ein modell sein für jene
die das paradies auf dieser erde suchen
das paradies muss man dort suchen wo man
es auch erreichen kann
in der kulturen kann man das sie ist
perfekt dafür große schriftsteller wie
thomas mann oder william faulkner haben
mit ihren romanen eine art paradies
erreicht aber in der realität kann man
nur erreichen dass sich gesellschaften
ständig verbessern
das ist möglich lassen sie uns doch von
ästhetischen programmen sprechen ihr
roman programme in den 60er jahren war
das programm eines totalen romans dass
die gesellschaft in all ihrer
differenziertheit möglichst
kontrastreich abbildet ihr großer freund
und auch widerpart garcía márquez hat
einen magischen realismus der er mit
fantastischen und allegorischen momenten
arbeitet wie ist denn das in der
gesellschaft heute brauchen wir heute
als schriftsteller ein neues
ästhetisches programm um diese
wirklichkeit den spiegel vorzuhalten
die heutige realität hat sich stark
verändert und ich glaube nicht dass es
beispielsweise in lateinamerika romane
gibt die diese realität ausdrücken
vielleicht weil sie sich noch im
wandlungsprozess befindet in
lateinamerika findet ein übergang stadt
die alten militärdiktaturen sind
verschwunden
wir haben demokratische regierungen die
allerdings alles andere als perfekt und
sehr korrupt sind
durch diesen wandel ist die gesellschaft
in einem umbruch begriffen der seinen
literarischen ausdruck noch nicht
gefunden hat
aber das wird kommen es ist sehr
interessant zu sehen dass es heute in
lateinamerika viele schriftsteller
frauen männer dichter romanautoren
essayisten das ist eine große
veränderung im vergleich zur
vergangenheit
früher war die literarische welt sehr
klein auch die leserschaft in
lateinamerika ist stark gewachsen
daher bin ich optimistisch und denke
dass mit dieser neuen generation eine
sehr vielfältige und kreative literatur
am entstehen ist aber wenn wir von einer
desorientierung sprechen
sie kann politisch sein sie kann aber
auch medial sein
wir haben ja auch ein ganz neues
mediales umfeld wie schätzen sie die
wirkungen dessen was wir die digitale
revolution nennen für die literatur
selbst ein sieg an ihr den garaus machen
die mediale revolution kann das ende der
literatur bedeuten immer stärker drängt
sich eine einfache literatur auf eine
literatur des unmittelbaren konsums die
kaum spuren hinterlässt die unterhaltsam
ist
und auch wenn mehr bücher chinas früher
haben sie weitaus weniger bedeutung
heute ist die konkurrenz sehr groß
wo der kleine bildschirm ersetzt als
große massenkultur nach und nach das
buch das bedaure ich wenn ich glaube
wenn die bildschirme gegen die bücher
gewinnen werden jene die für die
bildschirme schreiben eine viele
oberflächliche hre banalere künstliche
literatur produzieren als die literatur
der großen bücher es wird keinen
dostojewski nie ergeben keinen thomas
mann keinen tolstoi nein ich glaube dass
auch die beiden autoren immer wichtiger
werden
ich bin froh dass ich nicht mehr hier
sein werde wenn das passiert
da die converse diese mediale revolution
hat aber zu auch zu einer globalisierung
von kultureller wahrnehmung geführt und
eine dominanz die daraus folgt ist die
dominanz einer sprachlos des englischen
sehen sie eine kultur ab in denen das
englische eine homogenisierung der
kultur auch sprachlich global
herbeiführen wird dass wir am ende auf
diesem planeten fast nur noch eine
sprache sprechen
dazu wird es nicht kommen nein es wäre
sehr naiv zu glauben dass das passiert
spanisch zum beispiel ist eine sehr
lebendige sprache
sie konkurriert auf vielfältige weise
mit dem englischen
allein in den usa leben 50 millionen
spanischsprachigen menschen
das ist außergewöhnlich und wird sich
nicht einfach zurückbilden
ganz im gegenteil ich habe den eindruck
dass es sprachen die die koexistieren
werden
sie sprachen gibt deren kulturen sich
immer mehr durchsetzen werden und am
ende werden in diesem freien spiel des
kultur marktes bestimmte sehr universell
besprachen übrig bleiben unternehmen
werden sehr viel kleinere sprachen
weiter bestehen
die vor allem regional und national
benutzt werden aber insgesamt bin ich
eher optimistisch gestimmt ich glaube
wenn sich die demokratische kultur immer
stärker durchsetzt wird es am ende vor
allem frieden geben was natürlich sehr
wichtig ist und ich denke die präsenz
der englischen sprache ist überhaupt
nicht schlecht für die menschheit
es ist gut dass es unter den
verschiedenen sprachen eine wirklich
universelle gibt mit der wir uns alle
verständigen können
aber man könnte doch sagen das
aufflackern die renaissance des
nationalismus könnte etwas mit der angst
dieser kleineren sprachen zu tun haben
als sprachen als kulturen zu
verschwinden das mag vielleicht auf
wenige fälle zu treffen aber dieses
nationalistische kriterium sollten wir
nach und nach abschaffen deine stets der
zivilisation und den fortschritt im weg
worin besteht der fortschritt in diesem
bereich ich sehe den fortschritt darin
dass die grenzen allmählich verschwinden
das tun sie immer mehr und das ist gut
nicht wahr
das erschreckt die nationalisten sehr
und sie stützen sich sehr auf diese art
die europäische gemeinschaft zum
beispiel die entstehung europas hat eine
erschreckende wirkung auf viele menschen
sie befürchten ihre kleinen heimat zu
verlieren
sie glauben es gibt diese kleine heimat
aber sie existiert nicht mehr die große
technologische und kommunikative
revolution unserer zeit hat sie zum
verschwinden gebracht
ganz zu schweigen vom wirtschaftlichen
faktor die wirtschaft globalisiert sich
zusehends das ist sehr gut denn es
ermöglicht den armen ländern schnell aus
der armut herauszukommen
im vergleich zu früher aber sie sollten
nicht befürchten dass die kleinen
kulturen verschwinden
es gibt keinen grund warum das passieren
sollte ganz im gegenteil sie sprachen
vorhin und das fand ich sehr interessant
auch in bezug auf die kultur vom freien
spiel der ökonomischen marktkräfte ist
nicht gerade die kultur ein bereich die
man nicht ganz diesen marktkräften
überlassen darf ja die kultur sollte
nicht den händlern überlassen werden
selbstverständlich nicht
aber es gibt einen kulturellen markt auf
dem gewisse länder aufgrund ihrer großen
kulturellen errungenschaften in der
musik der literatur der malerei und der
philosophie die welt überfluten
sie sind zu beglückwünschen das sollten
wir nicht zurückweisen warum kein land
hat die pflicht auf kultureller ebene
besonders hervor zu stechen
manche haben das erreicht sehr zum
vorteil der menschheit kultur kommt der
ganzen menschheit so gut nicht nur dem
land in dem sie entsteht in der heutigen
zeit ist alles so redeten gerade wegen
der großen sozialen und intellektuellen
mobilität heute kann man nicht sagen
dass seine literarische bewegung aus
nordamerika aus england und aus
frankreich kommt das ergibt wenig sinn
was geschieht kommt uns allen zugute
und es schadet uns auch allen ich glaube
das ist eine der positiven aspekte der
globalisierung
sie ermöglicht es uns in der ganzen welt
zu geben
die kultur war schon immer
richtungsweisend kultur wahllokal sie
war immer international und kann allen
zugute
und in diesem bereich machen wir immer
mehr fortschritte
unser großes problem ist meiner meinung
nach die für die partner manchmal sehr
hinderliche präsenz der großen
kommunikationsmedien der kommunikation
die kultur die sie verbreiten ist eine
sehr arme kultur eine kultur die aus
wiederholungen gesteht aus karikaturen
eine kultur des unmittelbaren konsums
lassen sie mich ganz klar zum mediator
erst ganz kurz nach sagen weil es
nämlich den begriff der elite und den
wächtern der kultur
ins spiel bringt glauben sie dass wir in
unserer situation immer noch kulturelle
eliten haben müssen die diesen standard
für alle waren
nun ich denke die eliten unserer zeit
verschwinden immer mehr
aber ich halte es für einen fehler zu
denken dass die eliten unbedingt
verschwinden sollten
ganz allgemein ist in der kultur eine
spezialisierung zu beobachten eine
verfeinerungen gewissen bereichen die
eben nur eine elite zugänglich sind
einem sehr minoritäten sektor niemand
kann von der breiten öffentlichkeit
verlangen über die neuesten erkenntnisse
der linguistik bescheid zu wissen oder
über ein hervorragendes linguistisches
wissen zu verfügen
dass ihr zugang zu verschiedenen
kulturen verschaffen würde
das ist unmöglich das vorhandensein von
eliten ist also notwendig es ist
nützlich und wertvoll
gleichzeitig ist es zentral zu
unterscheiden was wichtig ist und was
nicht
es gibt heute einige philosophen vor
allem in frankreich die sagen endlich
haben wir eine demokratische kultur die
die ganze welt erreicht aber was die
ganze welt erreicht sind die telenovelas
im fernsehen von denen nur wenige
qualitativ hochwertig originell oder
kreativ sind und als wichtiger beitrag
zur kultur bezeichnet werden könnte
es ist unterhaltung dar und es ist gut
dass es unterhaltung gibt dagegen habe
ich nichts einzuwenden
ich schaue auch fernsehserien aber ich
vergleiche sie nicht mit der großen
literatur der großen musik unter der
großen lichtung ich finde es sehr
wichtig dass da unterschieden wird das
ist diese rangordnung
und der einzige weg das zu erreichen ist
über die eliten die großen kritiken zb
stammen von den eliten aus demokratische
hinsicht beliebten abzulehnen ist für
mich nach und greift die kultur
ansichten die letzte frage an einen
menschen der es wissen muss einen
freiheitsliebenden menschen wenn es ein
werk der literatur gibt es ihren sinn
für freiheit am besten zum ausdruck
bringt welches würden sie empfehlen ein
neuzeitliches werk oder ein klassiker
die können denn ich einen klassiker
auswählen dadurch dann wäre es das große
werk der spanischen sprache don
quichotte und getrottet ist eine ode an
die freiheit
don quichotte der landkreis ein freier
mann
ein mann der sich von allen anderen
unterscheidet weil er mehr an die bücher
glaubt als anders leben so wird er zum
wandern und diese irrsinn verwandelt ihn
für uns gewissermaßen in einem großen
helden
für mich ist er ein großer held er wagt
es anders zu sein und seine
individualität geben über allem anderen
zu verteidigen er glaubt an die freiheit
und beweist dies mit der art wie er sein
leben lebte ich denke dieses buch ist
vor allem deshalb weltweit so
erfolgreich weil es das ideal von
individualismus und freiheit
repräsentiert und dass wir liberale
glauben
vielen dank gern geschehen
es war mir eine freude und nächsten
sonntag sehen sie barbara bleisch beim
stammtisch es geht um die frage wie
viele menschen man überhaupt noch
verantwortlich in die welt setzen darf
sind kinder ein ego projekt nächsten
sonntag in der sternstunde
und für heute ist hier schluss vielen
dank und denken sie weiter
[Musik]